what's happening now when we started
designing websites we always invented
the wheel over and over again for a long
time nobody had figured out information
architecture so we all just made stuff
up
we made up we you know we said well this
one's gonna have 17 buttons and we'll
name them after the zodiac I mean it was
you know a wild and wooly thing and then
Peter morville and Louis Rosenfeld wrote
information architecture for the World
Wide Web and people started figuring it
out Jared spool and jakob nielsen's
started talking about usability and
people started figuring that out and
Steve Krug wrote about it very
beautifully and people started going oh
it's common sense applied to design oh
okay I get it what's happened and so
that was sort of the first phase of the
web that was if you can all these phases
and everything it's all kind of
artificial but the first phase of the
web was going from pirates doing
underground stuff making it up nobody
really having any idea how any of it
worked and that was so much fun and then
figuring out how usability information
architecture design on the web what our
standard screen sizes all that stuff so
we went through that phase what we're
going through now with open source and
with open source libraries especially is
that I'll take I'll talk about my least
favorite thing first so CSS is the
design language of the web and it's not
as easy to use as it ought to be and it
can be confusing especially if you're
new to it so certain people have created
CSS libraries which they give away where
they say well if you want a three-column
layout then do this it's not a tutorial
telling you how to make a three-column
layout that's sort of the first phase I
wrote some of those but and lots of
people wrote those this is a second
phase where instead of writing a
tutorial people are basically giving you
a bunch of code and saying here's how
this code works if you need to do a four
column layout or here's the grid
here's a ten-part grid that's 960 pixels
wide it'll fit very nicely at 1024 by
768 and if you want it you know if
want these proportions then use this
little snippet of code if we want these
proportions use this little snippet
that's useful it's my least favorite
because this there's no
one-size-fits-all for design and I think
well that can help you if you don't know
CSS make a CSS layout ultimately it
doesn't really educate everyone and it
doesn't allow designers to think outside
the box it's basically we're making a
box but mostly these days it's not
mostly you can use expression engine or
Drupal or basically tools that are kind
of like WordPress and you know or an
blog or kind of like blogging tools but
on steroids you can use those things and
there's a whole community of people out
there we have a site right now that is
currently running on a custom our own
content site our magazine is running on
a beautifully created custom content
management system it was written in Ruby
on Rails by Dan Benjamin it's awesome
and he's a brilliant developer and he
created it very quickly but he's also
very busy and when we need to modify
something we can't always get his
attention and he's the only person in
the world who knows how to come in and
modify it so we're transitioning and
taking it to expression engine them and
you know that's not a no-brainer process
that requires real developer power but
once you've done that once you've it's
sort of like transitioning to web
standards if you move from old fashion
markup to web standards there's sort of
pain the first time you do that because
you've got all this crap you don't know
what to do with it and it's like how do
I scrape the content out of all this
crap that was so used to surround it but
once you've done it you'll never have to
do it again once you've done it your
markup can stay the same forever even
though your layout may change radically
well it's the same with these tools once
you move from a what you're moving from
static to million-dollar CMS the pain
was all that learning and all that money
and licensing agreements and miserable
stuff now we have really powerful
comparatively easy to understand open
source content management systems or
proprietary with like similar expression
and in his proprietary but as a very
soon
a licensing agreement basically you pay
like $100 a year and that's it we're
really in a time now where a lot of
stuffs been invented we know how a lot
of stuff works we know a community means
on the web we know what magazine
publishing is on the web we're still
trying to figure out art direction on
the web but you know we figured a lot of
stuff out and people who in the past
might have you know you know just kept
their expertise to themselves are now
sharing it very generously in these
little frameworks and open-source
applications and other people are adding
you know writing Exede Oh mark Hewitt
who works for happy God created
extensions for expression engine like oh
the client wants to do this expression
engine doesn't do it out of the box
here's this thing I've invented it I'll
give it to the community to use so
that's where we are with